we begin in the united states where the
confirmation of amy
comey barrett to the supreme court has
given
this key political institution a
conservative majority for years to come
the senate approving her nomination by
52 votes to 48. her appointment was
opposed by
congressional democrats will have some
analysis after this report
after a month in the spotlight she
finally got to say these
me
words
judge amy coney barrett is heading to
the u.s supreme court
it's a privilege to be asked to serve my
country
in this office and i stand here tonight
truly honored and humbled
president donald trump was on hand to
celebrate one of his signature
achievements
locking in a conservative majority on
the supreme court
for many years to come this is a
momentous day for america for the united
states constitution
and for the fair and impartial rule of
law
cody barrett took her oath at the white
house only an hour
after the senate narrowly voted to
secure her nomination
with only one republican not supporting
the motion
democrats strongly opposed the
confirmation saying a supreme court
justice
shouldn't be appointed this close to an
election
let the record show that tonight
the republican senate majority decided
to thwart the will of the people
and confirm a lifetime appointment to
the supreme court
in the middle of a presidential election
opponents of coney barrett's nomination
say it paves the way for conservative
rulings
on abortion rights healthcare and lgbtiq
rights
coney barrett vowed that she will remain
independent
the oath that i have solemnly taken
tonight
means at its core that i will do my job
without any fear or favor
and that i will do so independently
of both the political branches and of my
own preferences
she'll take the second of her two oaths
on tuesday at a private ceremony
which will allow her to begin official
duties on the court
let's get more on this key appointment
now with boris foreman a professor of
political science at
bard college here in berlin good to see
you again professor
um how much does amy coney barrett's
confirmation
reshape this crucial institution the u.s
supreme court
i mean it is it is an important moment
and this is a six to three
a conservative majority on the supreme
court this is quite
an imbalance and this will shape major
issues and there are important questions
coming up just around the corner
one of them being about the presidential
election so this is a certainly an
important
moment yeah considering that this
supreme court
could rule on the presidential election
if there's difficulties especially with
the malk
uh the mail count as something a lot of
people are talking about do you see that
as a possibility
well uh just just yesterday the supreme
court already rejected the
uh the um uh the desire to extend
the the mainland ballots for wisconsin
similar decisions are just coming up
about
north carolina and pennsylvania so there
is already an important debate going on
and obviously people are thinking about
2000
about florida bush versus gore
and the supreme court decision to back
george w
bush at the time and similar things
might be coming up since this is a very
content
contentious election and the supreme
court might have to step in
that has a lot of people very concerned
the country was of course bitterly
divided
over this nomination and the issues
that the new supreme court justice is
set to rule on like public health care
that's another issue coming up you
mentioned the election could be won
do you see barrett putting her stamp on
things from the very beginning
beginning with for example health care
this is very contentious and the
democrats have been emphasizing that 20
millions might be left uninsured
if the affordable care act was to be
ruled
unconstitutional however i mean the
supreme court has already ruled on it
twice and
has upheld its constitutionality
so whether barrett is actually going to
tip the scale here is not entirely clear
also one thing we shouldn't forget is
that oftentimes conservative
members of the supreme court think also
of gorsuch or kavanaugh
who have also been heavily criticized do
tend to become more liberal
in the specific institutional context of
the supreme court so this is something
that might also happen with ibikoni
barrett
the democrats have been saying one way
to address
some of the concerns you've stated is to
expand
the size of the court do you see them
actually pushing that
well biden has been very hesitant on
doing this and i think there is some
danger in
in doing this because it would
politicize an institution that is
supposed to be
bipartisan or impartial rather and so
biden has rejected to come to any clear
conclusion he said he would he would
hold a panel of of scholars to
to come up with a decision or a question
i think it depends also a lot on the
framing
is this uh something that is done in
order to
rebalance the supreme court after the
republicans uh
contradictory uh process of
self-contradictory process really of
nominating emmy connie barrett
so um i think it depends on the framing
uh i think that biden will
try to do this only in the in the if if
push comes to shove professor boris
foreman from bard college
thank you very much thanks
you